[Applaudissements]
c'est sur du velours comme moi mon
velours
oui je peux te demander le butin service
oui c'est pire quand ça va ça va nous
déjà plus moche et est pas mal mais si
vous êtes mis sur le lourd ça revient
très fort c'est beaucoup plus beau c'est
vous qui avez donné des conseils
monsieur ça vous va très bien et alors
on peut montrer les soupers aux
téléspectateurs les se battent au 13
août
c'est que je me suis fait charrier au
bureau toute la journée
genre tu sautes d accueillir vos
chroniqueurs je sais ce qui s'est passé
nous et chaussures et tous les
téléspectateurs vont dire la même chose
que moi c'est ce qu'il espère ces
chaussures mettez votre porte et
chaussées du coin 47 et demi celui 43
sur la tête de ma mère est amoindri les
clips et de ouf et la queue du cac
le vélo est embrouillée non mais alors
je veux dire mettez une petite semelle
par en dessous vous étiez des
chaussettes de tennis affrontera crème
on a vraiment ça passera comme une
lettre à la poste je mettais des
chaussettes de tennis un peu épaisses et
une petite semelle par le cas vous dira
que mallory frère c'est la vie ce qui au
passage le tour c'est clair j'ai cru que
tu étais venir dynastar vous connaissez
pas la classe
allez on y va sans qu'on va rigoler
sylvan quel bel accueil
allez vas-y loulay alors toi parce que
je suis de sa famille l'attend pour
faire le qui douche les séries comme
chaque semaine il y à la pastille star
du paf où je réunis tous clé ce qui se
passe pendant les magnétos pendant les
pubs pendant les offres c'est 50
secondes inside
bienvenue dans sa corde seconde inside
de pmp pour commence tout de suite avec
cyril qui adore ses chroniqueurs
aujourd'hui je voulais dire que j'étais
très content de pouvoir enfin il les
adore à sa façon
vous êtes des gros des grossistes les
grossistes mais cette année les
chroniqueurs ont décidé de pas se
laisser faire un gros bateau là gros
pognon dans une voiture après le
problème de son la semaine dernière
problème de fumée
cette semaine son plateau pmp ah non
c'est juste le retour de doc gynéco en
tout cas ce qui est bien avec baba c'est
que chacun fait ce qu'il veut
vous donnez tous vos portables je peux
avoir un portable ya plein de gens qui
se plaignent donc vous donnez votre
portable vous donnez votre téléphone
vous ne plus les voir
alors je vous dis non mais c'est vrai je
te rappel si c'était une démocratie ça
se saurait tu veux te dire ça marche
très bien comme ça te fait des années
apparaît donc ça change
et puis pas de panique jean castex
l'annoncé hier vers la mantille elle
pourra faire ces uv avant 18 heures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une fois n'est pas coutume benjamin
castaldi est toujours le roi des vents
alors ici ça n'allait pas démissionner
[Musique]
et comme d'hab le mot de la fin si le
pas en baba cette garde je vous jure je
vais faire pipi sur la table ça y est
c'est fini pour cette semaine à la
semaine prochaine les loups merci alors
la chance est devenu apprend à faire
connaissance avec l'équipe mais merci à
vous d'être aussi nombreux le vendredi
je sais pas s'ils doivent d'abord
obtenir le monde attend voilà vous êtes
on s'amuse bien mais oui oui mais la
masse est inouï bien cgt lire ged s'est
pas encore fait chier dessus par un
groupe qui lui a fixé vers un plaisir
fou
ce soir je rigole mais je suis quand
même triste clic et 10 passes bébé parce
qu'on aurait pu assister à la naissance
d'un couple sur ce plateau
non non oui parce que tpm pc aussi de
l'amour un couple entre nicolas
pernikoff et tiffany mon voisin oui
j'adore le problème c'est qu'ils iraient
bien ensemble ben ouais désiré bien
ensemble mais bien ceux ci dirige ce
jour franchement je trouve ça un truc ça
sera un génie mais na waie prochain ah
ouais ouais
élégant tous les deux c'est un tracé où
vous êtes et les grands j'avais tous les
deux alors au niveau poitrine et les
plus proches de benjamin
[Rires]
sur la plage l'été le club et c'est bien
sûr et ce sont des pectoraux un jour
après bien sûr des pectoraux qui bouge
ça arrive avec du lait de bébé oui serré
le malheureusement cet amour ne pourra
pas se faire puisqu'ils un point de non
retour
pas un euro de nombreux cours qu'il
vient de tiffany mais en fait pas du
tout non ils viennent nicolas pernes et
comme la wii et l'aviez fait ainsi mais
vous savez tiffany moi je suis libre je
sois scorpion ascendant coeur à prendre
[Applaudissements]
je sais plus des techniques sont tous
les majeurs comment vous êtes majeur se
soit pas sans rigoler elle va le faire
corps et militer contre haut de
l'histoire et je n'aime pas que ses fans
mais ça peut être est ce qu ils sachent
à la base
oui j'aime bien un petit peu
méditerranéen comme ça j'ai dit la
vérité
non mais pourquoi on a pas d'âge tu fais
ni arrêté
tamare ma mère fait de très beaux tubes
s'ils voulaient venir manger à la maison
ce soir m
cosmi qui tout ça je connais un accord
avec nicolas donc regarder le magnéto
vous allez voir c'est pas pour tout de
suite une union entre nicolas tiffany
[Applaudissements]
du
tu veux que tu m'aies coûtera davantage
j'arrive pas ce qu'il va dire qu'ils me
lancer dessus
certains copains
[Musique]
il faut maintenant là dans la
boulangerie
ça peut être mentalement dans des eaux
moi j'ai envie tout seul est différente
et ce à quelques tentes y quelques
années de delphine la mienne je dirais
qu'il est honnête et j'embrasse mon ami
qui est dans la boulangerie alors
j'avais dès qu'il était sûr et mali mais
lui veut le cadet il à quelqu'un ces
mêmes amis nous c'est mon avis et bons
lots il a il à quelqu'un vous trouver
beau quand même c'est que c'est que tu
peux tu t'y vas quand même c'est à dire
tu prends vent sûrement mais tu
continues tu m'as mais c'est super c'est
vers ça peut être une technique de
drague de faire un temps on a rien à
[ __ ] ça attire la personne aurait en
fait vous pouvez capillairement y
retourne avec le dessus et voilà
d'accord assure un sermon de semaine en
semaine un jeu sans trêve la butte pas
non plus sur le jeu court morgan
[Rires]
confondu ma collaboratrice qui est là
d'ailleurs
non c'est pareil sur fond d'une
collaboratrice au côté du avec guillaume
genton guillaume genton à l'instant il a
donné un conseil matrimoniale à tiffany
et nicolas et puis tous les jours il
donne des conseils beauté dans
l'émission nantais mpk
[Rires]
donc vous avez recruté guillaume cette
année vous attendiez un chroniqueur
médias mais finalement vous êtes
retrouvé avec un vendeur de chez sephora
[Musique]
morning meeting
végétal à l'étude a fait découvrir
impose équipe c'est comme ça
[Musique]
c'est quoi après son exil c'est quoi
c'est un lait végétal pour les visages
si c'est gentil ça d'orange cette
vermine aux idées qui manquent d'éclat
genton c'est bio c'est bon projet alors
s'il vous savez très bien recevoir vos
chroniqueurs on l'a vu tout à l'heure
sur salvador également très bien
recevoir les invités après bienvenue
chez les new sur tf1 bienvenue chez ba
ba pour les invités
fait que la présentation du gard j'adore
et je vais le garder la fine mouche qui
pète aux états unis ce qu il fait le
voyage privé le moral avec notre
françois durpaire un très beau gosse
historien spécialiste des états unis
mais je peux vous dire il n'y a pas une
mouche qui pète aux états unis sans qui
sont pour eux ça va mon claude ça va
bien merci de votre habitat si je veux
faire la présentation des chroniqueurs
je pense qu'il va passer une année 2021
très sympa vous étiez parfait pour
incarner un groupe mais pas pour chanter
selon lui puisque vous chantez comme une
merde ça va fêter semaine c'est donc une
vision pour ce méga chanteur a créé vous
dites mais aujourd'hui comme une merde
c'est l'histoire c'est cette histoire il
de sa bonne série on termine avec claude
alexis vous l'avez vu il était dans le
magnéto gens l'adorent il a fait une
prédiction à benjamin castaldi
la semaine dernière il lui a dit que
cette année et bien ils n'auraient pas
de soucis financiers de soucis de compte
en banque mais c'est normal parce que
benjamin cette année il veut être un
businessman
vous savez c'est quoi le pire cyril
alors si on retrouve le sms est
quelqu'un qui vous qu'il guillaume dans
les gammes à dans l'équipe dans l'équipe
de tpm paix c'est la non mais regardez
que le téléspectateur sur tous les
domaines au dessus - un sms de cynthia
contrit a été chroniqueur qui m'a mis
très très beau guillaume genton ce soir
guillaume il est très beau c'est vrai
mais coûté bon vous voyez moi je vous
trouve très beau si guillaume ainsi
indiqué guillaume apparemment à la
rédaction m'a dit qu'elle avait rien
fait depuis le mois d'octobre
donc c'est peut-être lié de dévoiler
tous je suis d'avis que j'ai dévoilé
jeudi
mais oui
sympathique et benjamins ils devaient
pas mes problèmes cette année
j'aime bien moi ça laisse à tous les
toits non non j'ai pas entendu ces gens
pensent que belle [ __ ] bassam à cette
année c'est un businessman
mais le problème c'est qu'il veut faire
de l'argent sur notre dos cyril non on
l'appelait la rédaction benjamin
castaldi le relou de wall street qui
veut faire des pas des parfums avec toi
non non et à vosnon nous proposer un
acompte de 25 minutes c'est à dire que
tu veux que je donne 25 millions ces
bâtonnets ma maison
[Musique]
merci
ils médicaments
cette fois on met la voiture est la
règle au protocole
je produis j'assemble j'en ai vu des
patients
[Musique]
et oui je suis en plein business à lui